the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
time which is now two weeks ago we
started to talk about the signals and
systems approach by which I mean think
about a system by the way it transforms
its input signal into an output signal
that's kind of a bizarre way of thinking
about systems I demonstrated that last
time by thinking about a mass in a
spring something that you have a lot of
experience with but you probably didn't
use this kind of approach for thinking
about it over this lecture and over the
next lecture what I'd like to do is show
you the advantages of this kind of
approach and so for today what I'd like
to do is talk about how to think about
feedback within this structure and I'd
like to also think about how you can use
this structure to characterize the
performance of a system in a
quantitative fashion so first off I want
to just think about feedback feedback is
so pervasive that you don't notice it
most of the time you use feedback in
virtually everything that you do here's
a very simple example of driving a car
if you want to keep the car in the
center of your lane something that many
people outside of Boston at least think
is a good idea then you are mentally
doing feedback you're constantly
comparing where you are to where you'd
like to be and making small adjustments
to the system based on that when you
think of even the most simplest systems
like the thermostat in the house I'm not
talking about a cheap motel right the
cheese motels don't do this but in a
real house there's a thermostat which
regulates the temperature that's
important because of the temperature
suddenly drops they would never do that
of course but if the temperature ever
dropped it could compensate for it
here's one of my favorite examples
feedback is enormously pervasive in
biology there's no general rules in
biology but to a first cut everything is
regulated and in many cases the
regulation is amazing here's an example
from 602 one
where it's illustrating the system that
your body uses to regulate glucose
glucose delivery from food sources to
every cell in your body which is crucial
to your being cognizant and mobile so
and the idea is that it does that with
amazing precision despite the fact that
eating and exercise are enormous ly
episodic in order for you to remain
healthy and functional you need to have
something between approximately 2 and 10
mili moles per liter of glucose in your
blood at all times worried to go higher
than that systematically you would
develop cardiac problems and could lead
to even congestive heart failure if you
have lower than 2 million moles per
liter
you would go comatose that's a very
narrow range 2 to 5 especially because
we what we eat is so episodic what we
when we exercise is so episodic it's
amazing and just to dramatize how
amazing it is how much sugar do you
think circulates in your blood right now
well if you convert 5 million moles per
liter and if you assume the average
person has about 3 liters of blood which
is true and if you calculate it that can
talk to 2.7 grams that's this much this
is 2.7 grams of table sugar by
comparison so this is how much sugar is
in your blood now this is what's keeping
you healthy this is what's keeping you
from becoming kill with dose or not how
much sugar do you think is in this
exactly we call that the theory of
lectures I don't want to look like an
idiot so my props makes sense this is
the amount of sugar in a can of soda the
numerically this is 39 grams okay that's
a lot more that's more than 10 times
there's more than 13 times this much so
when you down one of these it's very
important that the sugar gets taken out
of the blood quickly and it does and
that happens by way of a feedback system
and the feedback system is illustrated
here basically the feedback involves the
hormone insulin and that's why insulin
deficiency is such a devastating disease
finally everything we do has feedback in
it think about how your life would be
different if it didn't even a simple
task like removing a light bulb would be
virtually impossible except for the fact
that you get feedback from everything
your hands amazing you have touch
sensors you have proprioceptive sensors
you have stress sensors on the muscles
and ligaments and they all coordinate to
tell you when to stop squeezing on the
light bulb so you don't break it that's
all completely amazing and what we'd
like to do then is think about that kind
of a system a feedback system within
this signals and systems construct as an
example I want to think through the wall
finder problem that you did last week in
design lab I'm sure you all remember
that in that problem we were trying to
move the robot to a fixed distance away
from the wall and we thought about that
as a feedback system comprised of three
parts a controller a plant and a sensor
we wrote difference equations to
characterize each of those parts and
then we figured out how to solve those
difference equations to make some
meaningful prediction about how the
robot would work so just to make sure
you're all on board with me here yeah
here's a question for you these are the
quests these are the equations that
describe the wall finder problem
how many equations and how many unknowns
are there take 20 seconds talk to your
neighbor figure out an answer between 1
and 5
unlike during the exam actually you are
allowed to talk
No
see T and K are known
okay so what's the answer number one two
three four or five everybody raise your
hands let me see if I got the end I got
the answer okay so I raise your hands
come on everybody vote if you're wrong
just blame it on your neighbor right you
had a poor partner that's that's the
idea right so you can all vote and you
don't need to worry about being wrong
and you're all wrong so it all works out
well okay so I don't like the so the the
predominant answer is number two
I don't like number two can somebody
think of a reason now that you know the
answer by the series of lectures the
answer is not - why isn't the answer -
oh God
so the exciting you can't before or
after doing substitutions and
simplifications and I meant to account
before you do simplification any other
issues that's the key question so I want
to think about this as a system in of
algebraic equations and if I do that
then there's a lot of them right and in
particular if I think about so it looks
like there's three equations the problem
with that approach is that there's
actually three equations for every value
of engine right if you think about a
system of equations that you could solve
with an algebra solver you would have to
treat all the ends separately that's
what we call the samples approach so
here's a way you could solve them you
could think about what if I K and T are
parameters so they're known they're
given what if my input signal is known
say it's a unit sample signal for
example what would I need to solve this
system well I need to tell you the
initial conditions so in some sense I
want to consider those to be known
so my knowns kind of comprise T and K
the initial conditions for the output of
the robot and the sensor er all of the
input signals because I'm telling you
the input and asking you to calculate
the output my unknowns are all of the
different velocities for all values of n
bigger than is bigger than or equal to 0
because I didn't tell you those all of
the values of the robots output it
samples and bigger than 0 all the values
of the sensor output for values and
bigger than 0
so I get a lot of unknowns infinitely
many and I get a lot of equations also
infinitely many more so the thing I
wanted you to think about is if you're
thinking about solving difference
equations using algebra that's a big
system of equations by contrast what if
you were to try to solve the system
using operators now how many equations
and unknowns you see by the theory of
lectures okay raise your hand or talk to
your neighbor so you can blame your
neighbor top your name on get a good
alibi
so the idea here is that if you think
about operators instead so that you look
at a whole signal at that time then the
the equations each equation only
specifies one relationship among signals
and there's a small number of signals
right so if I think about the knowns
being KT the parameters and the signal
di and if I think about the unknowns
being the velocity the output in the
sensor signal then I get three equations
in three unknowns so one of the values
of thinking about the operator approach
is that it just simply reduces the
amount of things you need to think about
it reduces complexity that's what we're
trying to do in this course we're trying
to think of methods that allow you to
solve problems by reducing complexity we
would like altom utley to solve very
complicated problems and this operator
approach is an approach that lets you do
that it does a lot more than that - it
also generates new kinds of insights so
it lets you focus on the relations but
the relation is now not quite the same
as we would have expected from algebra
now the the relation between the input
signal and the output signal is an
operator we're gonna represent the
operation that transforms the input to
the output by this symbol H we'll call
that the system functional it's an
operator it's a thing that when operated
on X gives you Y it's also convenient
and that's this is one of the main
purposes of today's lecture it's also
convenient to think about H as a ratio
we like to think of it that way because
as we'll see there's a way of thinking
about H as a ratio of polynomials in R
so two ways of thinking about it we're
trying to develop a signals and systems
approach for thinking about feedback we
want to think about the input goes into
a box the box represents an operation we
will characterize that by a functional
we'll call the functional H
the functional when applied to the input
produces the output and what we'd like
to do is infer what is the nature of
that functional and what are the
properties of the system that that
functional represents okay to see that
you're all with me think about the wall
finder system think about the equations
for the various components of that
system when expressed in an operator
form and figure out the system
functional for that system figure out
the ratio of polynomials that can be in
our that reprobate is represented by H
take 30 seconds talk to your neighbor
figure out whether the answer is 1 2 3 4
or 5
yeah
so what's the answer 1 2 3 4 or 5 more
voter participation right blame it on
your partner right okay virtually a
hundred percent perhaps so the idea is
algebra right you solve the operator
equations exactly as though they were
algebraic here I've started with the
second equation and just done
substitutions until I got rid of
everything other than do and di so I
expressed V in terms of ke then I
express E in terms of di minus R do then
I'm left with one equation that relates
de oh and di which I can solve for the
ratio and the answer comes out there
which was number three point is that the
you can treat the operator just as
though it were algebra so that results
in an enormous simplification but what
we want to understand is what's the
relationship between that functional
that thing that we just calculated and
the behaviors these are the kinds of
behaviors that you observed with the
wall finder system when you built the
wall finder system depending on what you
made K you could get behaviors that were
monotonic and slow faster and
oscillatory or even faster and even more
oscillatory and what we'd like to know
is before we build it how should we have
constructed the system so that it has a
desirable behavior and incidentally are
these the best you can do or is there
some other set of parameters that's
lurking behind some door that we just
don't know about and if we could
discover it it would work a lot better
so the question is given the structure
of our problem what's the most general
kind of answer that we can expect and
how do we choose the best behavior
out of that set of possible behaviors so
that's what I want to think about for
the rest of the hour and a half and I
want to begin by taking a step backwards
and look at something simpler the idea
is going to be the same as the idea that
we use when we studied Python I want to
find simple behaviors think about that
as a primitive and combine primitives to
get a more complicated behavior so I
want to use an approach that's very much
pcap find the most simple behavior and
then see if I can leverage that simple
behavior to somehow understand more
complicated things so let's think about
this very simple system that has a
feedback loop that has a delay in it and
a gain of P naught what I want to do is
think about what would be the response
of that very simple system if the input
were a unit sample so find Y given that
the input ax is Delta in order to do
that I have to start the system somehow
I will start it at rest you've all seen
already I'm sure that rest is the
simplest assumption I can make I'll say
something at the end of the hour about
how you deal with things that are not at
rest for the time being we'll just
assume rest because that's simple assume
that the system is at rest that means
that the output of every delay box is 0
that's what rest means if the output of
this starts at 0 then the output of the
scale by B naught is also 0 and if
that's 0 and if the input is 0 because
I'm at time before 0 then the output is
0 indicated here so now if I step then
the input becomes 1 because Delta of 0
is 1 the output of the delay box is
still 0 so the first answer is 1 the 1
just propagates straight through the add
box then I step and the one that was
here goes through the R and becomes 1
the one
goes through peanut and becomes P not
but at the same time the one that was at
the input goes to zero because the input
is one only at time equals zero so the
result then is that after one step the
output has become P naught this
propagated to one that became P naught
added to zero and it became P naught so
now the answer which had been 1 is P
naught on the next step a very similar
thing happens the P naught that was here
becomes the output of the delay gets
multiplied by P naught to give you P
naught squared gets added to 0 to give
you P naught squared etc the thing that
I want you to see is that the output was
in some sense simple every value the
value simply increased as P naught to
the Andal geometrically there's another
way we can think about that we can think
about it I just did the sample by sample
approach but the whole theme of this
part of the course is the signals
approach if I think about the whole
signal at one fell swoop
then I can develop an operator
expression to characterize the system
the operator expression says the signal
Y is constructed by adding the signal
acts to the signal P not our Y if I
solve that for the ratio of the output
to input I get 1 over 1 minus P naught R
again going back to the idea that I
started with that we're gonna get ratios
of polynomials in R now the R is in the
bottom and now I can expand that just as
though it were an algebraic expression I
can expand 1 over P 1 over P naught R in
a power series by using synthetic
division the result is very similar in
structure to the result we saw in sample
by sample it consists of an ascending
series in R which means an ascending
number of delays every time you increase
the number of delays by one you also
multiply the amplitude by p9 so this is
in fact the same kind of result but
viewed from a from a signal point of
view finally I want to think about it in
terms of block diagrams same idea I've
got the same feedback system but now I
want to take advantage of this ascending
series expansion that I did and think
about each of turn each of the terms in
that series as a signal flow path
through the feedback system so one the
first term in the ascending series
represents the path that goes directly
from the input to the output passing
through no delays the second term in the
series P naught R represents the path
that goes to the output loops around
comes back through the adder and then
comes out in traversing that more
complicated path it picked up one delay
and one multiplied by P naught second
term two loops third term three loops
fourth term for loops the idea is that
the block diagram gives us a way to
visualize how the answer came about it
came about by all the possible paths
that lead from the input to the output
those possible paths all differed by a
delay and that's why the the
decomposition was so simple each path
corresponding to a different number of
delays through the system that won't
always be true for more complicated
systems but it is true for this one this
flow diagram also lets you see something
that's extremely interesting cyclical
flow paths which are characteristic of
feedback feedback means the signal comes
back cyclical flow paths are are
required that the in that transient
inputs generate persistent outputs they
generate persistent outputs because the
output at time n is not triggered by the
input at time n it's triggered by the
output
n minus-1 it keeps going on itself
that's fundamental to feedback there's
no way of getting around that
that's what feedback is and it also
shows why you got that funny-ass Allah
torii behavior in wall finder there
wasn't any way around that feedback men
that you were looping back that men that
there was a cycle in your in the signal
flow paths that means that even
transient signal signals that go away
very quickly like the unit-sample
generate responses that go on forever so
that's a fundamental way of thinking
about systems systems are either
feed-forward or feedback feed-forward
means that the path there are no cyclic
paths in the system every path that
takes you from the input to the output
no path in the system that takes you
from the input to the output has a cycle
in it that's what a cyclic means that's
what feed-forward means a cyclic
feed-forward those all have responses to
translate inputs that are transient that
contrasts with cyclic systems a cyclic
system has feedback and will have the
property that transient signals can
generate outputs that go on forever okay
how many of these systems are cyclic
easy questions 15 seconds talk to your
neighbor
okay so what's the answer how many
okay virtually under design crack the
engine screen I have illustrated the
cycles in red so there's a cycle here
there's two cycles in this one and
there's a cycle here so the idea is that
when you see a block diagram one of the
first things you want to characterize
because it's such a big difference
between systems is whether or not
there's a cycle in it if there's a cycle
then you know there's feedback if
there's feedback then you know you have
the potential to have a persistent
response to even the transient signal
okay so if you only have one loop of the
type that I started with where we had
just one loop with an R and a p9 then
the question is as you go around the
loop does the signal do the samples get
bigger or smaller or do they stay the
same
that's a fundamental characterization of
how the simple feedback system works so
here if on every cycle the amplitude of
the signal diminishes by a
multiplication by 1/2 that means that
the response ultimately decays
mathematically it goes on forever just
like I said previously but the amplitude
is decaying so practically it stops
after a while it becomes small enough
that you lose track of it by contrast if
every time you go around the loop you
pick up amplitude if the amplitude here
we're multiplied by 1.2 then it it gets
bigger so the idea then is that you can
characterize this kind of a feedback by
one number we call that number the pole
very mysterious word I won't go into the
origins of the word for our purposes it
just simply means the base of the
geometric sequence that characterizes
the response of a system to the unit
sample signal
so here I've showed an illustration of
what can happen if P is 1/2 P is 1 P is
1.2 what you can see is decay
persistence divergence
can you characterize this system by P
naught and if so what does P naught
yes No
yeah it's up and virtually everybody's
getting the right answer the right
answer is to so we like our surprise we
like negative numbers so we're allowed
to think about polls being negative in
fact by the end of the hour we'll even
think about polls having imaginary parts
but for the time being this is fine if
the poll were negative what that means
is the consecutive terms in the
unit-sample response the response of the
system to a unit sample signal the unit
sample response the response the unit
sample response can alternate in sign
okay so this then represents all the
possible behaviors that you could get
from a system a feedback system with a
single poll if a feedback system has a
signal single poll the only behaviors
that you can get are represented by
these three cartoons if P naught is
bigger than one so here I've laid this z
axis contains all possible values of P
naught if P naught is bigger than 1 then
the magnitude diverges and the signal
grows monotonically if the poll is
between 0 and 1 the response is also
monotonic but now it converges towards
zero if you flip the sign the relations
are still the same except that you now
get sign alternation so if the P naught
is between 0 and minus 1 which is here
the output still converges because the
magnitude of the poll is less than 1 but
now the sign flips and if the poll is
below minus 1 then you get alternation
but you also get divergence the
important thing is we started with a
simple system and we ended up with an
absolutely complete characterization of
it this is everything that can happen
that's a powerful statement when I can
analyze a system even if it's
and find all the possible behaviors I
have something so if you have a pole if
you have a simple system with a single
pole this is all that can happen there
might be offsets there might be delays
the signal may not start until the fifth
sample will but the signals will the
persistent signal will either grow
without bounds decay to zero or do one
of those two with alternating sign
that's the only things that can happen
which of course begs the question well
what if the system is more complicated
okay so here's a more complicated system
the system cannot be represented by just
one pole in fact the systems are
complicated enough you should think
through how you would solve it right you
should all be very comfortable with this
sort of thing so if you were to think
about what if I had a system like so
and I want it to be 1.6 and minus minus
0.63 what would be the output signal at
time 2 if the input were a unit sample
signal okay
as with all systems that we're going to
think about we have to specify initial
conditions the simplest kind of initial
conditions we could think about would be
rest if I thought about this system at
rest then the initial outputs of the
ours would be 0
that's at rest four times bigger four
times less than zero the input would be
zero zero times one point six plus 0
times minus 0.63 plus zero would give me
zero now the clock ticks when the clock
ticks it becomes time zero at time zero
the input is one this zero just
propagated down to here but that's what
zero so nothing interesting happened at
the ARS but now my output is one now the
clock ticks what happens when the clock
ticks this one propagates down here this
zero propagates down here but that was
zero this one goes to zero because the
inputs only one at time zero so what's
the output one point six now the clock
ticks what happens
well this one comes down here this one
point-six comes down here this zero
becomes another zero because the input
has an infinite stream of zeros after
the initial time so what's the output
well it's one point six times one point
six plus 1 times minus 0.63 so the
answer is number three yep okay so yeah
I forgot to write it up there so the
answer is in red down here one point six
squared minus 0.63 okay the point is
that is slightly more complicated to
think about than the case with a single
pole and in fact if you use that logic
to simply step through all the responses
you get a response that doesn't look at
a geometric the geometric sequences that
we looked at previously either
monotonically increase monotonically
decrease toward zero or give one of
those two things and alternated this
does none of those behaviors so the
point is Freeman is an idiot he spent
all that time telling us what one pole
does and now two poles does something
completely different right now so the
response is not geometric the response
grows and then decays it never changes
sign it does something completely
different from what we would have
expected from a single pole system as
you might expect from the theory of
lectures that's not the end of the story
so the idea is to now capitalize on this
notion that we can think about operators
as algebra if our expressions behaved
like I told you they did last lecture if
they behaved as entities upon which that
if they if they are isomorphic with
polynomials as I said then this is a
very cute thing
we can do with this system to make it a
lot simpler the thing we can do is
factor if we think about the operator
expression to characterize this system
the thing that's different is that
there's an R squared but if our
operators work just like polynomials you
can factor polynomials right that's the
factor theorem from out your problem and
if i factor it I get two things that
look like first order systems pow wow
that's good the factored form means that
I can think about this more complicated
system as the Cascade of two first order
systems oh that's pretty good in fact it
doesn't even matter what order I put
them in because as we saw as we've seen
previously if the system started the
initial rest then you can swap things
because they obey all the principles of
polynomials which include commutation so
what we've done then is transformed this
more complicated system into the Cascade
of two simple systems and that's very
good even better we can think about the
complicated system as the sum of simpler
parts and that uses more intuition from
polynomials if we have one over a
polynomial a second-order polynomial we
can write it in a factored form here but
we can expand it in what we call partial
fractions we can expand this thing in
this song and if you think about putting
this over a common denominator and
working out the relationship this
difference 4.5 over 1 minus 0.9 R minus
3.5 over 1 minus 0.7 R that's precisely
the same using the normal rules for
polynomials that's precisely the same as
that expression but the difference from
the point of view of thinking about
systems is
normos we know the answer to that one
that's the sum of the responses to two
first-order systems so we can write that
symbolically this way we can think about
having a sum system that generates this
term this term is a simple system of the
type of that we we looked at previously
that then gets multiplied by 4.5 right
I'm just factoring again I'm saying I've
got something over something which means
that I can put something in in each of
two different parts of two things that I
multiply together and I can think about
this as having been generated by this
system and you just add them together
the amazing thing is that that says that
despite the fact that the response
looked complicated it was in fact the
sum of two geometrics so it wasn't very
different from the answer for a single
pole what I've just done is amazing I've
just taken something that had you
studied the difference equations and if
you had studied the block diagrams it
would have been very hard for you to
conclude that something this complicated
has a response that can be written as
the sum of two geometrics by thinking
about the system as a polynomial in R
it's completely trivial it's a simple
application of the rules for polynomials
that you all know so what we've shown
then is that this complicated system has
a way of thinking about it as just two
of the simpler systems the complicated
response that grew and decayed that's
just the sum difference really 4.5 minus
3.5
it's the weighted difference of a part
that goes like point 7 to the end and a
different part that goes like point 9 to
the N so what we've done is we've showed
that in fact so so far we've got two
results the N equals 1 case
the first order polynomial in our case
the one pole case that's trivial it's
just a geometric sequence the response
is just as geometric sequence if it
happens to be second-order
this is second-order because when you
write the operator expression the thing
in the bottom the polynomial in the
bottom is second order second-order
polynomial in our the second-order
system has a response that looks like
two pieces each piece looks like a piece
that was from a first-order system and
in fact that idea of generalizes if we
have a system that can be represented by
linear difference equation with constant
coefficients that will always be true if
the system was constructed out of the
parts that we talked about adders games
delays if the system is constructed out
of adders gains and delays then it will
be possible to express the system in
terms of one difference equation general
form is showed here Y of n is can be
constructed out of parts that are
delayed versions of Y and delayed
versions of X if you do that then you
can always write the operator that
expresses the ratio between the output
in the input as the ratio of two
polynomials that will always be true so
this now is the generalization step
right we did the N equal one case we did
the N equals two case and now we're
generalizing we will always get for any
system that can be represented by a
linear differential in--are difference
equation with constant coefficients we
can always represent the system
functional in this form then just like
we did in the second-order case we can
use the factor theorem to break this
polynomial in the denominator into
factors that comes from the factor
theorem in algebra then we can
re-express that in terms of partial
fractions
and what I've just showed is that in the
general case regardless of how many
delays are in the system if the system
only has adders gains and delays
I can always express the answer as a sum
of geometrics that's interesting
that means that if I knew the basis for
all of those geometric sequences I know
something about the response the bases
are things we call poles if you knew all
the poles you know something very
powerful about the system for every pole
so every one of the factors corresponds
to a pole and by partial fractions
you'll get one response for each pole
the response for each pole goes like
Pole to the N you know the basic shape
you don't know the constants but you
know the basic shape of the response
just by knowing the poles we can go one
one more step which makes the
computation somewhat simpler
I used the factor theorem here I'm using
the fundamental theorem of algebra which
says that if I have a polynomial of
order n I have n roots the poles are
related to the roots of the our
polynomial the relationship is take the
functional substitute for our 1 over Z
we express the functional as a
polynomial as a ratio of polynomials in
Z the poles are the roots of the
denominator okay so so recapping I
started with the first order system I
showed you how to get a second order
system I showed that in general you can
use the factor theorem to break down the
response of a higher order system into a
sum of responses of first order systems
now I've showed that you can use the
fundamental theorem of algebra to find
the poles directly and then by knowing
the poles you know
each of the behaviors the monotonic
divergence monotonic convergence or
alternating signs and so here's the same
example that I started with worked out
by thinking about what are the poles the
poles are 0.7 and point nine which we
see by a simple application of the
fundamental theorem of algebra ok we got
a long way by just thinking about
operators as polynomials we haven't done
anything that you haven't hadn't done in
high school right polynomials are very
familiar and we've mapped ice it we've
made an isomorphism between systems and
polynomials okay make sure you're all
with me here's a higher order system how
many of these statements are true zero
one two three four or five talk to your
neighbor or get an answer
so how many are true zero one two three
four or five labeled on your neighbor
right you weren't packing but I didn't
hear you got hot how many are true zero
one two three four or five raise your
hands
they can't all be true are they mutually
contradictory make sense
it's none of the above that sounds like
they're right okay so so you've
eliminated voice which one is true how
many how many statements are true
looks like about 75% correct what's
ready deals how do I figure it out
what's my first step what do I do
operators absolutely so turn it into
operators so take the difference
equation turn it into operators the
important thing to see is that there are
three Y terms take them all to the same
side and I get an operator expression
like that the ones that depend on X
there are two of them that's represented
here the thing that is critical for
determining poles is figuring out the
denominator the poles are going to come
from this one after I get the polynomial
in R the ratio of two polynomials in R I
substitute 1 over Z for each R so for
this R I get 1 over Z for this R squared
I get 1 over Z squared then I want to
turn it back into a ratio of polynomials
in Z so I have to multiply top and
bottom by Z squared and when I do that I
get this polynomial astray shio of
polynomials in Z so the poles are
the poles are the roots of the
denominator polynomial in Z the poles
are minus 1/2 and plus 1/4
so the unit-sample response converges to
0 what would be the condition that that
represents something about the
polynomial in the bottom would all
second order systems have that property
that the unit-sample response would
converge to 0 louder absolute value of
the poles has to be less than 1
if the pole if the magnitude of the
poles is less than 1 then the response
magnitude will decay with time right so
that's true here and it would be true so
long as the none of the poles have a
magnitude exceeding 1 there are poles
that are half in the quarter no that's
not right it's minus 1/2 of 1/4 there's
a poet I have no that's not right
there's a poet minus 1/2 there are two
poles yes that's true none of the above
no that's not true so the answer was
told okay everybody's comfortable we've
done something very astonishing right we
took an arbitrary system and we figured
out a rule that lets us break it into
the sum of geometric sequences the
response we can always write the
response to a unit sample signal we can
always write as a weighted sum of
geometric sequences and the number of
geometric sequences in the sum is the
number of poles which is the order of
the operator that operates on Y okay so
we've done something very powerful
there's one more thing that we have to
think about and then we have a complete
picture of what's going on think about
when you learn polynomials one of the
big shocks was that roots can be complex
okay what would that be what would it
mean if we had a system whose roots
whose poles were complex-valued so first
off this is such a system exist while
here's one okay I just pulled that out
of the air if I think about the
functional one over one minus R plus R
squared if I convert that into a ratio
of polynomials in Z and then find the
roots I find that the roots have a
complex part the roots are half plus or
minus root 3 over 2 J so there's a
complex part there's an imaginary part
so the question is what would that mean
or is perhaps that system just
meaningless right well complex numbers
working out gibran and complex numbers
we're here too
so the fact that a pole has a complex
value in this in the context of signals
and systems simply means that the pole
is complex that the base of the
expediter exceeds that base is complex
so that means that we can still rewrite
the denominator which was 1 minus r plus
r squared we can rewrite that
denominator in terms of a product of two
first-order are polynomials the
coefficients are now complex but it
still works the algebra still works
right that has to work because that's
just polynomials that's why polynomials
behave right so we now we can still
factor it we can still use the factor
theorem in fact we can still use the
fundamental theorem of algebra to find
the poles by the Z trick that's fine
we can still use partial fractions all
of these numbers are complex but the
math still works the funny thing is that
it implies that the fundamental modes by
fundamental mode I mean the simple
geometric for the case of a first-order
system more complex behaviors for high
systems the mode is the time response
associated with a pole so the modes are
in this case complex sequences so if I
think of the so in general the the modes
look like P naught to the n here my
modes are simply complected have a
complex value so what did I say they
were so the the poles were half plus or
minus so my mode simply looked like that
right same thing the strange thing that
happened was that those modes those
geometric sequences are now have complex
values the first one up here if I just
look at the denominator these
coefficients mean that it's
proportionate to the mode associated
with this which is that which has a real
part which is the blue part and the
imaginary part which is the red part the
other pole there were two poles plus and
minus the other pole just flips the
minus sign the the imaginary part sorry
so if I have imaginary poles all I get
is complex modes complex geometric
sequences and a way of thinking about
that an easier way of thinking about
that is thinking about so when we had a
simple real pole we just had P naught to
the n that's easy to visualize because
we just think about each time you go
from 0 to 1 to 2 to 3 it goes from 1 to
P not to P naught squared to P naught
cube here when you're multiplying
complex numbers it's easier to imagine
that on the complex plane think about
the location of the point 1 think about
the location of the point P not think
about the location of the point P naught
squared and in this particular case
where the pole was 1/2 plus or minus
square root of 3 over 2 times J
this would be Pole to the zero this is
pole to the one this is poled squared
pole cubed as you can see when you have
a complex number the trajectory in
complex space can be complicated in this
case it's circular the circular
trajectory in the complex plane
corresponds to the sinusoidal behavior
in time so there's correlation between
the way you think about the modes
evolving on the complex plane and the
way you think about the real and
imaginary parts evolving in time it
seems a little weird that the response
should be complex right we're studying
this kind of system theory
primarily because we're trying to gain
insight into real systems we want to
know how things like robots work how
does the wall finder work what would it
mean if the wall finder went to position
one plus the square root of three over
two J that doesn't make sense
so there's a little bit of a strange
thing going on here why how is it that
we need complex numbers to model real
things that doesn't seem to sound right
what the answer is that if the
difference equation had real
coefficients as they will for a real
system if you think about a real system
like a bank account the coefficients in
the difference equation are real numbers
not complex numbers if you think about
the wall finder system become the
coefficients in the wall finder system
the coefficients of the difference
equations of the coefficients in the the
coefficients of the difference equations
will describe the wall finder behavior
we're all real numbers if you have a
polynomial here I'm thinking about the
denominator polynomial if we try to find
the roots of a polynomial and if we find
a complex root if the coefficients were
all real it follows that the complex
conjugate of the original root is also a
root
that's pretty simple if you think about
what it means to be a polynomial if you
think about a polynomial is whatever so
I've got 1 plus Z plus Z squared plus
blah blah blah if all of the
coefficients 2/3 minus 16 if all of
those coefficients were real then the
only way that if the only way this the
if Z were if P if P were a root of this
polynomial then P star would have to be
a root 2 because the complex conjugate
if you complex conjugate each of the Z's
it's the same thing as complex
conjugating the whole thing because the
coefficients are real valued so the idea
then is that if I happen to get a
complex root for my system that can be
described by real valued coefficients it
must also be true that it's complex
conjugate is a root if that happens the
two roots co conspire so that the modes
have canceling imaginary parts you can
prove that I'm not worried about you
being able to prove that I just want you
to understand that if you have two roots
that are complex conjugates they can
conspire to have their imaginary parts
cancel and that's exactly what happens
here in this example the example that I
started with where the system was 1 over
1 minus R plus R squared the unit sample
responses showed here you can write that
as the sum of sinusoidal and
cosinusoidal signals and the sum that
falls out has the property that the
imaginary parts cancel it's still useful
to look at the imaginary parts the same
as it is when you're trying to solve
polynomials it's useful because the
period of all of these signal
is the same if I think about the period
of the individual modes if I think about
the period of P not to the end half plus
or minus root 3 over 2 J to the end the
period of that signal I can see in the
complex plane this is the N equals 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 the period is 6
if I were to take the negative 1 I would
go around the circle the other way this
would be the zero term 1 2 3 4 5 6 etc
both of the modes the geometric sequence
associated with the two complex
conjugate poles both of those modes have
the same period they're both sexes as
does the response to the real part so
you can deduce the period of the real
signal by looking at the periods of the
two complex signals ok so think about
this system here I've got a system whose
responses showed here I'm going to tell
you that the response was generated by a
second-order system that is to say a
system whose polynomial was second-order
whose polynomial in R was second-order
which of these statements is true I want
to think about the pole as being a
complex number here I'm showing you the
complex number in polar form it's got a
magnitude and an angle and I'd like you
to figure out what must the magnitude
has been and what must the angle has
been
so what's the utility why did I tell you
the pole in terms of its magnitude and
angle rather than telling it to you in
its Cartesian form of a real and
imaginary part
what's good about thinking about
magnitude and angle where if I break the
pole into magnitude and angle and if I
think about the mode the modes always
have the form all right the modes are
always of the form P naught to the N if
I think about modes as having a real
part and an angle when I raise it to the
N something very special happens what
happens you can separate it what is our
e to the J Omega raised to the N that's
the same as R to the N e to the J and
Omega it's the product of a real thing
times a very simple complex thing what's
simple about the complex thing the
magnitude is everywhere 1 e to the J the
magnitude of that term so all of the
magnitude is here none of the magnitude
is here all of the angle is here none of
the angle is here I've separated the
magnitude in the angle so it's very
insightful to think about poles in terms
of magnitude and angle because it
decouples the parts of the of the mode
so I can think then of this complicated
signal that I gave you as being the
product of a magnitude part and a pure
angle part from the magnitude part I can
infer something about our
our is the ratio of the enth 1 to the N
minus 1 1 so R is a lot bigger than 1/2
in fact R in this case is 0.7 0.9 7 and
this is pure angle this lets me infer
something about the oscillations in fact
I can say something about the period the
period is here's a peak here's a peak 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 the periods 12
if the Peary is 12 what is omega well Oh
Meghan is a number that by the time I've
gone to n times it I got up to Omega is
a number such that by the time I got up
to 12 times it I got up to 2pi what's
omega 2 pi over 12 so it's about 1/2 so
that's a way that I can infer the form
of the answer of the answer right I ask
you what pole corresponds to this
behavior well the decay that comes from
the real part that comes from R to the N
the oscillation that comes from the
imaginary part and I can figure that out
by thinking about the period and
thinking about that relationship so I
know then that the answer is so the
answer then is this one R is between 1/2
and 1 and Omega is about 1/2 okay one
last exam what's wrong button one last
example and that has to do with so what
we've seen is a very powerful way of
decomposing systems
so that we can always think about them
in terms of poles and complex geometrics
which we will call modes poles and modes
and that behavior works for any system
in an enormous class of systems so I
want to think about one last one which
is Fibonacci sequence you all know the
Fibonacci sequence you've all programmed
it we started with that when we were
doing Python we made some illustrations
about recursion and all that sort of
thing by thinking about it now I'm going
to use signals and systems to do the
same problem so Fibonacci was interested
in population growth how many pairs of
rabbits can be produced from a single
pair in a year if it is suppose that
every month each pair B gets a new pair
from which the second month it becomes
productive okay it's not quite the same
English I would have used from this
statement you can infer a difference
equation I've written it in terms of X
what do you think X is X is the input
signal and here I'm thinking about X as
something that specifies the in the
initial condition this is the thing I
alluded to earlier one trick that we use
to make it easy to think about initial
conditions is that we embed them in the
input so in this particular case I'll
think about the initial condition
arising from a delta function if I think
about X as a delta then the sequence of
results y naught y 1 y 2 y 3 from this
difference equation is the conventional
Fibonacci sequence it would correspond
to what if you had a baby rabbit one
baby rabbit that's the one in generation
0 that's the Delta right so the input is
a way that I can specify initial
conditions and that's a very powerful
way of thinking about initial conditions
so here's the problem
I've got one set of baby rabbits at time
0 they grow up they have baby rabbits
which grow up at the same time the
parents had more baby rabbits at which
point more babies grow into bigger
rabbits and big rabbits have more babies
etc etc etc etc etc so the question is
so you all know that right you you all
know about Fibonacci sequence it blows
up very quickly what are the poles of
the Fibonacci sequence
the difference equation looks just like
the difference equations we've looked at
throughout this hour and a half we can
do it just like we did all of the other
problems we write the difference
equation in terms of r we rewrite the
system functional in terms of a ratio of
two polynomials in R we substitute R
goes to 1 over Z deduce a ratio of
polynomials in Z factor the denominator
find the roots of the denominator and
find that there are two poles the poles
for the Fibonacci sequence are 1 plus or
minus the root of 5 over 2 well that's
curious it's no recursion there it's a
different way of thinking about things
there are two poles the first pole the
plus one one plus the root of five over
two corresponds to a pole whose
magnitude is bigger than one it explodes
there it is
the second one is a negative number so
the first one is the golden ratio 1.618
dot dot dot the second one is the
negative reciprocal of the golden ratio
which is minus 0.618
dot dot dot and those two numbers
amazingly conspire so that there's some
horrendous as they are is an integer
thank that's the integer that we
computed here so we've used the van
actually before to think about the way
you structure programs iteration
recursion that sort of thing here by
thinking about signals and systems we
can think about exactly the same problem
as though it had as poles there's no
complexity in this problem it doesn't
take n or N squared or n log n or
anything to compute its closed form
right the answer is pull 1 to the n plus
pull two to the end that's it that's the
answer so what we've done is we found
the whole new way of thinking about the
Fibonacci sequence in terms of poles and
more than that we found that that way of
thinking about poles works for any
difference equation of this type and we
found that poles this way of thinking
about systems in terms of polynomials is
a powerful abstraction that's exactly
the same kind of pcap abstraction that
we used for python